bom bom dia pessoal meu nome é stéfany
mas falando aqui da mauá faço engenharia
eletrônica eu estava andando aqui um dia
pelo campus e receber um a tap como todo
mundo tem a tap falando devem falar um
pouquinho no ted sobre inteligência
artificial e aí na hora eu pensei putz
eu vou falar sobre inteligência
artificial eu trabalho com isso eu tenho
aula sobre isso eu vivo nesse mundo mas
vou falar no ted você vê naquele palco
fiquei super nervosa ansiosa começou a
fazer ferrou certo que eu faço agora eu
comecei a pensar putz que os tedx tem
diferencial que fazem as pessoas
lembrarem deles que os tedx tank mar com
as pessoas
então comecei a pensar nos pede que eu
já vi que me marcaram que eles têm
diferencial que eles né porque eu lembro
deles até hoje
e aí lembrando começando a pensar um
pouco esse é o ted que mais me marcou
até hoje gente eu tinha 17 anos e não
faz muito tempo né e eu vi a cidade aqui
e pasmem vocês não sabem marcar o sapato
de vocês é hotel mor em apenas três
minutos explica como nós não sabemos ao
ar nos sapatos e ele fala como uma
simples mudança na nossa vida consegue
trazer grandes benefícios para nós é o
que ele fala que nós fizéssemos las um
pouquinho diferente
nós conseguimos fazer o nosso desamarra
se muito menos bom para contextualizar
eu era monitora de movimento juvenil
judaico e um dia nós estávamos todos os
monitores discutindo sobre inovação é
como nós vamos falar com as crianças
e aí o nosso coordenador mostrou
exatamente sped e eu lembro que na hora
que eu vi esse ted eu só pensei na
seguinte fato pô eu não sei amarrar os
sapatos
eu estou treinando amarrar meu sapato de
modo errado até hoje e até hoje eu
continuo com eles amarrado certo e bom
falando um pouquinho mais sobre sapatos
e seu irmão rafael e ele tem 7 anos e um
dia ele chegou em casa para minha mãe
falou mamãe eu quero aprender na marra
sapatos e aí minha mãe foi lá certo tem
toda uma questão motriz noé
pensem um pouco né como amarrar os
sapatos você tem que pegar um cadarço
período cadarço
tem toda uma questão muito complicada
certo por trás disso aí minha mãe foi
ensinando ensinando até que uma hora ela
sentiu sacolés é fini
vez vem aí né aí eu fui lá comecei a
tentar ajudar ele é um pouco ele foi
aprendendo na escola devagarzinho até
que uma hora ele conseguiu e agora não
importa certo qual o sapato e liuzzi ele
consegue amarrar os sapatos da mesma
maneira
vocês devem estar falando stf é louca
porque ela vinha falar de inteligência
artificial e ela tá falando de sapatos
mas vocês entenderam isso que aconteceu
com rap
vocês entenderam que a inteligência
artificial o rafa é a nossa máquina de
treinamento certa ele não sabia mal
sapatos mas ótimo nós tínhamos
exatamente o passo a passo de
treinamento
pega um cadarço pega o cadarço faça um
laço para outro laço e nós vamos
treinando ele se ele teve um momento de
treinamento equipamento e treinamento é
muito árduo porque tem um erro ou acerto
e é muito difícil principalmente uma
criança mas no momento que ele conseguiu
ele consegue generalizar e aí não
importa certo aí ele fica feliz ao ver
que ele tem na foto e bom já que não
tenha a audácia de razão pede em três
minutos e nem temor fez eu vou enrolar
vocês só mais um pouquinho tá bom vamos
lá que a inteligência artificial se a
gente pegar a definição mais clara vocês
nunca vão achar assim certo um exemplo
mas eu gosto muito dessa aqui que
inteligência artificial é a capacidade
da gente fazer algoritmos de treinamento
para a generalização mas fica essa
generalização a capacidade de a gente
pegar tudo isso daí iremos lá as
funcionalidades humanas seja ela de fala
de ver e escutar isso tudo aqui volta
para o treinamento e aí a gente entra
num ponto muito importante da tendência
inicial o treinamento
existe uma coisa por trás que nós
falamos muito em relação à ética certo
quem vai treinar a máquina
somos nós seres humanos então no momento
fui eu e minha mãe foi átila da escola
nós estávamos treinando a nossa máquina
que no caso é o raf
então nós passamos tudo isso é do nosso
conhecimento pra ele eu mesmo coisa que
acontece aqui
quando nós vamos passar algum
conhecimento da nossa máquina depende de
nós ensinar ela do modo certo porque é
muito fácil extrapolar e generalizar
quem está falando aqui e para o lado
errado e eu digo assim em inteligência
artificial é um grande guarda chuva que
nós temos neco
teremos o guarda-chuva nós temos
diversas coisas atrelados a ela
quem é que com certeza já escutou alguma
coisa como machine learning e pulando em
computação cognitiva redes neurais eu
posso ficar falando aqui meia hora de
termos da gente
cada um de fato sim tem sua
peculiaridade tem né
não podemos explicar cada um deles mas
tudo de hoje se eu quero que seja
inicialmente de uma coisa é exatamente
isso tudo se trata do grande
guarda-chuva de treinamento para a
generalização mas ok stephen a gente
entendeu o porquê certo entendemos que a
inteligência artificial mas por que
investir nisso aí certo porque todo
mundo fala tanto sobre isso mas não sei
se vocês sabem hoje 80% de todos os
dados de todas as empresas que têm tá
todos os dados que a gente tem
disponível são dados não estruturados
que o dado não estruturada é muito fácil
de falar desde uma sabe que alguém
tomando agora porque não entendendo nada
do que estou falando
é uma imagem é um áudio é um vídeo é uma
transcrição é algo que não tenho de hora
certo o a coisa que a gente pode fazer
uma célula que a gente tem de parar de
fazer o famoso crude
o crude era aquela idéia que a gente
tinha uma célula a gente consiga falar
por si x maior que 2 realize isso agora
imagina eu aqui no palco a gente quer
fazer uma análise
assim a stefhany estiver sorrindo faça
isso não é tão simples certo pra isso a
gente precisa passar nossas capacidades
do ser humano para a máquina e uma vez
que ela treinada e você explica pra elas
se estiver certa relação realize isso
ela vai aprender e vai conseguir
analisar e aí sim nós entendemos a ideia
mas o melhor de tudo inteligência
artificial consegue trabalhar nos dois
mundos e é muito curioso que a gente
consegue ver a evolução da inteligência
artificial prata nos filmes certo
eu me lembro primeira vez que eu vi o
homem bicentenário era pequena eu falei
cara e nunca vai acontecer certo e hoje
estou nesse mundo totalmente
implementada e mas o mais curioso de
tudo isso é a evolução que a gente
consegue ver primeiro o homem
bicentenário é inteligência artificial
melhor que eu certa o robô sendo de
grande
certo o que vai ganhar de mim vai fazer
coisas melhores
depois no segundo passo que a ue a
inteligência artificial sendo
e aí a gente tentou reproduzir e aquino
ela no último é inteligência artificial
comigo e ela está comigo a gente pode
ser muito interessante falar isso mas
inteligência artificial não está só
comigo mas está com vocês e é muito
curioso que muita gente acha que a
inteligência artificial ainda não foi
democratizada mas sim todos têm acesso a
isso e para contar um pouquinho eu
queria voltar um pouco da minha história
faz mais ou menos dois anos entrei na bm
na área de outsourcing de pesquisa eu
tenho três patentes meu nome nós
desenvolvemos alguns projetos trabalhei
com suas brilhantes e sempre trabalhando
lá falando de moto moto moto eu falei
cara se eu começar a entender que é isso
um certo trabalho né
vamos começar a pesquisar se não ficar
para trás eu comecei a pesquisar que
quer o o som é muito curiosa história
dele porque foi realmente andando junto
com a minha história
o outro começou em 2011 no jd
e é um jogo muito curioso de o perder
porque o apresentador ele dá uma
resposta das pessoas e elas têm que
devolver com uma pergunta então sejam
bem vindos ao jd é o jogo mais mas o
jeito mais simples de explicar para
vocês
fg que você estava no desafio chegar pra
você falasse aracnofobia que vocês
poderiam responder o que é medo de
aranha é fácil certo gente comecei no
modo easy vai agora ser chegar pra você
falasse era um médico tá político com o
plano de 50 anos em 5 a 1 complicou
certo mas podia ser o jk certo esse
exemplo que eu dei era um sujeito mais
simples
tá que tem dentro jjd realmente é bem
complexo
os exemplos que eles vão lá mas o que o
curioso que eu queria falar e como o
outro chegou lá ele foi treinado
novamente treinando com toda a base da
equipe e ele não estava ligado na
internet para não ser injusto ele ganhou
o desafio mas mais do que ganhar o
desafio pensar na questão voltando
aracnofobia eu chego pra vocês e falará
com fobia que o cérebro de vocês nesse
momento para falar qual o medo de aranha
vocês entenderam o contexto certo a
aracnofobia
a ver com aranha 6 pesquisaram em algum
momento nossa cabeça que você já
aprendeu sobre isso uma vez que aprendeu
sobre isso você consegue mentalizar e
verbalizar pensa em uma máquina fazendo
isso aqui certo e até então ótimo era
simplesmente uma máquina de perguntas e
respostas
então o pessoal da ibm como eu investi
bastante falar poxa nós precisamos
fechar o ciclo certo começaram a focar
mais no desenvolvimento do o som e vamos
fechar o ciclo de inteligência
artificial e no momento que eles
fecharam eles criaram e pinhais e
pinhais são application programming
interface diz que qualquer pessoa
qualquer um que está aqui pode consumir
watson e ao invés de falar de projetos
megalomaníacos certo eu queria mostrar o
exemplo que nós tivemos
eu estava num desafio de programação 36
horas sim eu sou meio geek gente e nós
estávamos lá desenvolvendo eu estava
junto com o pessoal e que quem são esses
bonequinhos eles são os media box nele é
um projeto aberto dbm qualquer pessoa
pode imprimir esse robozinho do laser
com impressora 3d
mas o mais legal é que dentro dele tinha
um ótimo então eles falavam tinham que
reconhecia quanto de água tinha uma
planta ea partir disso ele ligava tinham
que cuidava de crianças nem que estavam
dentro do hospital
gente isso é um caso complexo de
democratização não tá porque isso é pra
mim isso é pra mim que têm programa
certo pra vocês aqui pode ter qualquer
tipo de gente
vocês devem estar pensando pô isso é
muito fácil você está a crescer
sabe programar se resolve fácil pra
gente que certo tem toda uma questão por
trás de como nós estamos trabalhando
junto com a inteligência artificial mas
gente quem não tá com isso no bolso
certo
estou com muita coisa na mão então fica
difícil a netflix youtube
spotify siri vocês estão junto com
inteligência artificial
vocês estão programando a inteligência
artificial tempo todo
vocês não perceberam mas quem aqui não
pegou agora um filme no netflix ea i
mostra até meu caso eu gosto de ver
essas coisas de tecnologia mas hoje vive
um romance no qual o romance que aparece
pra mim é um filme que pode ser que você
goste
o ella certo onde há romance homem
máquina porque porque isso certo porque
o netflix que tem uma inteligência
artificial entendeu o meu comportamento
ele foi treinado para entender o
comportamento das pessoas
uma vez feito isso ele generaliza então
no meu caso já que eu tenho uma certa
tendência ele generalizou pode ser que
até que ele esteja errado às vezes
porque eu quero ver aquelas coisas bem
água com açúcar adam sandler certo mas
poxa ele está seguindo por um caminho
certo
então vocês também estão com
inteligência artificial o tempo todo ela
está sendo cada vez mais democratizado é
importante nós entendermos que ela já
está conosco
stéfany seu tempo está quase acabando
não acha que está na hora de falar da
analogia da caixa de fósforos
nessa isabella gente eu programei ela e
ela é a voz do outro um português
isabel é como é que você sabe disso aí
ué
trabalhamos muitas horas juntas nesta
apresentação não é mesmo
me deixa orgulhosa ea rádio aí
engraçadinho sei
valeu tabela pode deixar então eu
programa é isso gente e eu queria falar
de um assunto muito importante eu
expliquei pra vocês o que eu expliquei
pra vocês porque mas então um ponto e aí
certo que a inteligência artificial tem
a ver com a gente vem numa caixa de
fóruns
nós somos os fósforos e eu acredito
muito claramente que a inteligência
artificial ea pista não é o que acontece
em um momento que nós conseguimos passar
um fósforo na pista ascendente um fogo
certo
acredito que no momento que nós seres
humanos conseguimos aprender que a
inteligência artificial está aqui
não sabe poderá para nos criar chama a
gente vai criar uma inovação
mas se a gente ficar posso por aí dentro
vossa num vivo é certo vai ficar aí não
tem problema a gente vai continuar
andando mais inteligência artificial vai
continuar se desenvolvendo mas ela tá
aqui pra nos ajudar
se não ficou claro um exemplo de uma
menina que trabalha comigo que
infelizmente a mãe dela está com câncer
e a iaa amanhã fazer uma operação e ela
chegou para o médico falou aí doutor
como é que se prepara certo antes da
operação ele falou 'bom eu leio três
artigos
dois dias antes da operação e aí a
menina falou bom considerando isso
matemática de poder um email artigo por
dia certo com a chance dele lei alguma
solução que seja exatamente sobre o
câncer por probabilidade muito pequena
passamos todos os artigos possíveis
sobre câncer por uma máquina que ela
seja treinada e aí dois dias antes nós
fazemos um relatório para esse médico
com a chance de trazer resposta exata
sobre o câncer
certo ou se não um juiz que vai julgar
uma pessoa e um advogado está lendo
todas as jurisprudências possíveis certo
e aí ele precisa salvar essa pessoa
estava instalar e exatamente a prova do
crime que vai salvar ele ou talvez a
incriminar e melhor melhor das pessoas
que conseguem ler e ter memória
fotográfica e leitura dinâmica ele não
vai conseguir tudo mas se a gente passar
por uma máquina máquina vai ter poder
ano a pessoa ou talvez somente uma
menina que está apresentando no ted uma
máquina está vendo ela está apresentando
e vai falar ó tá na hora de acabar certo
eu fui ponderada pela máquina vocês nem
poderá ter uma máquina mas a gente está
se transformando
isso depende da gente a gente precisa
aceitar essa chama em um momento que a
gente aceitar essa chama a gente traz o
benefício para nós vocês perceberam que
talvez tudo que a gente precisa amarrar
os sapatos de outra maneira
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]